لقد كان أسبوعًا مضطربًا آخر بالنسبة
للبابا الذي دائمًا ما يصدر أخبارًا أه
بدأ الجدل هذا الأسبوع
بأخبار مكالمة فيديو أجراها البابا فرانسيس
مع الشباب الكاثوليك في
روسيا أه وصفهم فيها ورثة
الأم العظيمة روسيا  ثقافة عظيمة
وتقليد إنساني عظيم، وقد
استنكر متحدث باسم
الحكومة الأوكرانية تلك اللغة باعتبارها
دعاية إمبريالية روسية أجبرت
الفاتيكان على إصدار توضيح يقول
إن البابا لم يكن ينوي تعزيز
الطموحات الإمبراطورية لأي شخص لمجرد
تشجيع الشباب الروسي على الترويج
لأفضل ما لديهم.  الثقافة ثم أه البابا
اتضح في لقاء مع اليسوعيين
خلال رحلة أخيرة إلى البرتغال
مخاطبا الكاثوليك في الولايات المتحدة
قائلا أن بعض منتقديه المحافظين
متخلفين
أه وأنهم يستبدلون الأيديولوجية
بالإيمان تعليقات واضحة لم
تنزل  حسنًا، في بعض
الدوائر الكاثوليكية الأمريكية المحافظة، وحتى
بينما نتحدث، يقوم البابا فرانسيس
بواحدة من أبرز
الرحلات الشعبية في التاريخ، وهي أول
رحلة بابوية على الإطلاق إلى منغوليا،
مجتمع بوذي بأغلبية ساحقة يضم
أقل من 1500 كاثوليكي ولكن مجتمع يقع على
الحدود  تمنحه كل من روسيا والصين
الفرصة لإشراك هاتين
القوتين العظميين خاصة فيما يتعلق
بالأزمة في أوكرانيا، لذلك مرة أخرى،
البابا البالغ من العمر 86 عامًا والذي تعرض لبعض
المخاوف الصحية في وقت سابق من هذا العام، ولكن
على الرغم من كل ذلك، يظل فرانسيس بابا
بدون رئيس.  إيقاف التبديل